la technique du Racou c'est cette
technique qui passionne depuis plusieurs
années Yannick Conan c'est une technique
japonaise du 14ème siècle et qui
consiste à faire en deuxième cuisson un
choc thermique c'est-à-dire on va sortir
la pièce à 1000 degrés par rapport à
l'extérieur où il fait on va dire 30
degrés et ça va faire craqueler les
émaux ensuite on va plonger la pièce
rouge de feu dans de la cire qui va s'en
fumer et ça va noircir les parties non
émaillées de la pièce c'est donc tout
naturellement une pièce fabriquée selon
cette technique qu'elle propose au jury
du Prix Célimène je suis passionné de
céramique de sculptures particulièrement
et de la technique du Raku et que c'est
quand c'est un peu spécial j'avais envie
de voir par rapport aux yeux des autres
ce que ce que donnerait une exposition
d'une de mes sculptures
donc je me suis si vous l'ai mis
en exposition pour avoir des réactions
de savoir si ce que je faisais pouvait
éventuellement plaire aux autres le prix
c'est l'hymen qui lui donne l'audace
d'exposer ses créations et surtout de
les vendre me dire que je pouvais je
pouvais m'exposer je pouvais me vendre
éventuellement moi je suis pas après si
vous voulez gagner beaucoup de sous mais
le pouvoir continuer c'est de racheter
mes matières qui viennent de France
puisque j'utilise un grès qui vient de
Saint-Amand qui est un gris chamotté
donc une terre très résistante qui
n'existe pas la Réunion désormais
Yannick s'est fait une petite place dans
le monde de la sculpture mais ça va plus
prendre l'âge
je continuerai tant que je pourrais en
espérant que je peux le faire encore un
certain temps oui voilà les projets ben
c'est toujours la même histoire je fais
partie de l'associations d'art arrêt
tradition les rencontres alternatives
donc je fais des expositions d'art
régulièrement et bon je des pièces voilà
cette passionner de céramique
collectionne aussi les pièces des autres
sur son étagère ces acquisitions
côtoient ses propres créations j'achète
à d'autres céramistes des choses que je
ne fais pas moi-même comme c'est bols
qui sont une céramiste très très réputée
maintenant
et ça faisait de la porcelaine ce que je
ne fais pas ça ce sont des infumages
également avec des patines que je ne
fais pas donc j'achète ce que je ne fais
pas Yannick ne cherche pas à gagner
beaucoup d'argent elle souhaite juste
pouvoir acheter ses matières premières
qui viennent de France le grec qu'elle
utilise n'existe pas ici de ce greeness
pourtant des sculptures inspirées par la
Réunion et les pays lointains sa manière
à elle de métisser là